news closer to home coveted cases on the
rise in the clark county school district
as we near the end of the second week of
classes we've heard directly from staff
members and parents who are concerned
they say that some safety protocols are
too vague kate houston is live in our
newsroom to break down the cases and
report on why
some are frustrated with the contact
tracing process kate
yes well behind me is the ccsd coveted
19 case tracker and here you can see 75
cases have been reported this week
that's up from 43 yesterday 408 have
been reported this month now parents and
staff are wondering how many positive
cases need to happen before more action
is taken
it has been stressful parents and staff
say the school year is off to a rocky
start there is what is supposed to
happen but then there is some time what
happens a top concern is contact tracing
schools will notify anyone who has come
in close contact with a positive case
which is defined as someone within 6
feet for 15 minutes but some are worried
this is not effective since it does not
necessarily apply to other students
within the same household how do you put
a cap on who should be quarantined
how do we know
that those measures are being followed
if we're only just generally told that
someone has come up superintendent dr
jesus jarrah says they're collaborating
with the health district and county on
this we notified that the person that's
nice to be notified as far as the
contact tracing
rest assured that we're doing everything
in collaboration
with the health experts to make sure
that the top priorities to keep our
employees and our staff safe and our
kids but once quarantined some parents
say the problems are continuing it's
just chaotic tina tatum's son came into
contact with a positive case and is now
doing virtual learning but i'm able to
hear the curriculum and they're not
getting what they need at home so i can
understand why parents are wanting to
send their kids to school because they
are not getting what they need she's now
wondering how many more positive cases
need to happen before stricter measures
are put into place we have to stand
united
everybody has to speak up it can't it
can't just be one person
well once a positive covet 19 case is
reported those who are not directly
contacted by the school or the health
district are considered a low risk
exposure that's like if you were to go
shopping or if you were to attend an
event reporting live kate houston 8 news
now